buon pomeriggio a tutti io appunto per
il comune di milano mi occupo di
partecipazione cittadinanza attiva open
data
ed è per questo che sono qui soprattutto
per parlare di open data e soprattutto
per parlare di trasparenza che è molto
legato al tema dei dati aperte il comune
di solito la prima cosa da spiegare e ma
che cosa vuole dire partecipazione
trasparenza tutti pensiamo agli
assessorati più classici trasporti
l'urbanistica quando si parla di comuni
e quindi a seconda del genere di
pubblico che si incontra quando si fanno
delle seminari degli appuntamenti in
pubblico bisogna specificare un po di
che cosa si sta parlando per farlo credo
che possa essere utile fare un salto
indietro di una quarantina d'anni nel
1976 ci sono state delle elezioni
politiche in italia ha partecipato al
voto il 93,3 per cento degli aventi
diritto quindi un numero molto grande
erano anni in cui i partiti come il
partito comunista all'epoca facevano un
milione 800 mila tessere persone che si
scrivevano ai movimenti politici e
partecipano alla vita civica alla vita
politica delle nazioni erano dei momenti
in cui c'erano le prime radio libere e
posti come il parlamento quante volte
l'avete sentito dire la casa di vetro il
luogo delle istituzioni
la più completa apertura e trasparenza
erano sì trasparenti sulla carta sulla
costituzione già da diversi anni dallo
statuto albertino figuriamoci nei
rendiconti parlamentari ma per esempio
nessuno poteva sapere esattamente quello
che succedeva lì dentro perché non
c'erano per esempio le dirette
radiofoniche delle sedute parlamentari
incomincia troppo nel 76
l'avventura di radio radicale conoscere
per deliberare questo motto di einaudi e
iniziavano a trasmettere integralmente
senza mediazioni senza tagli
senza rielaborazioni giornalisti che
quindi senza che qualcuno si frapponesse
tra la produzione del contenuto e la
fruizione perché ma perché c'era un
movimento che chiedeva a queste cose
c'erano degli attivisti che lo facevano
a proprie spese addirittura che creavano
queste precondizioni per fare
trasparenza erano gli open data la
trasparenza degli anni 70 oggi abbiamo
molta più tecnologia ma abbiamo molta
meno partecipazione le ultime elezioni
comunali nel 2016 hanno visto la
partecipazione al voto per esempio in
una grande città come roma di circa il
50 per cento degli aventi diritto il
partito che è quello che ha ereditato
insomma la storia del pci in italia ha
neanche 400.000 iscritti quindi ridotto
ad un quarto un quinto di quelli che
erano solo 40 anni prima insomma la
attenzione per quello che sono le
attività della della civitas nostra
stare insieme collettivo sono molto meno
seguite dai cittadini
e vero che si parla molto di più di
trasparenza di partecipazione sono tanti
devo dire i colleghi in altre città
italiane che hanno delle deleghe simile
alle mie dai comuni maggiori hanno tutti
istituito dei degli assessorati che
lavorano con i dati che lavorano con la
partecipazione
un po perché va di moda un po perché
forse questo venir meno della volontà
civica di partecipare alle decisioni
comuni deve avere come risposta delle
novità qualche nuova soluzione per poter
mantenere un'attenzione che va scemando
e allora sempre con un po di ritardo
arrivano anche i provvedimenti normativi
nel 1966 negli stati uniti d'america
veniva approvato il freedom of
information act che garantiva l'accesso
a tutte le informazioni del della
pubblica amministrazione per tutti i
cittadini che ne fanno richiesta
in italia abbiamo aspettato il 2016 per
avere una
legge simile però la buona notizia in
questo caso è che oggi qualsiasi
documento della pubblica amministrazione
può essere richiesto a qualsiasi
cittadino anzi da qualsiasi persona
senza che ci sia da dimostrare il perché
uno chiede o vuole ottenere un qualsiasi
genere di documento della pubblica
amministrazione abbiamo fatto quindi
passi in avanti sono tanti ormai i
comuni che fanno della politica di
apertura dei dati e delle informazioni
delle delle buone pratiche sono il
comune di milano ha un portale dove
vengono esposti i propri dati i propri
dati statistici i propri dati geografici
abbiamo un geoportale come la maggior
parte dei comuni
qual è il problema che anche in questo
caso a fronte di un grande avanzamento
tecnologico oggi possiamo seguire le
sedute del consiglio in streaming online
possiamo dire la nostra sui social
possiamo scaricare e vedere moltissime
informazioni delle pubbliche
amministrazioni ma alla fine dei conti
quello che manca è forse la
collaborazione civica nel poter fruire
questi dati è queste informazioni
e allora per quanto le pubbliche
amministrazioni si diano da fare per
aprirsi quello che ci serve è forse un
momento di formazione civica e di
ragionamento e di
incentivazione dei cittadini ad usare
queste opportunità dei dati aperti delle
informazioni della partecipazione per
riappropriarsi dello stare insieme del
vivere comune del dl poter sentire come
proprio quello che è la vita civica di
tutti i livelli dal comune alle
istituzioni più alte e questo è l'unico
modo che noi abbiamo oggi a disposizione
per fare in modo che quelle che sono il
grandissimo sterminato patrimonio
informativo delle pubbliche
amministrazioni diventino veramente
valore diventino veramente un bene
comune e le pubbliche amministrazioni
hanno a disposizione una quantità
inestimabile di dati dai dati sul
traffico e dati sulla salute dati
demografici ai dati sui prezzi ai dati
veramente su sull'anzianità delle case
piuttosto che su dove sono ubicati i
servizi
questi dati sono valori sono valori
economici sono valori sociali sono
valori anche storici per che
ricostruiscono come è cambiato il nostro
territorio come sono cambiate le nostre
professioni come sono cambiati
le i temi che ci interessano
è quindi fondamentale che siano le
comunità a sapere ea ragionare di quelli
che sono queste possibilità di
riappropriarsi dei dati perché comunque
sia anche se ormai siamo assistiti alla
tecnologia produrre liberare questi dati
è un costo bisogna metterli su
piattaforme digitali bisogna metterli in
internet
bisogna creare delle tabelle bisogna
fare in modo che siano informati
indicizzabili ricercabili raggiungibili
per tutti non solo per chi è nativo
digitale o conosce bene i computer e
allora questo costo è bene che sia
affrontato innanzitutto con delle
priorità e le priorità ci possono essere
indicate possono venire solo da chi da
questi dati tra e delle informazioni tra
e della conoscenza e da questa
conoscenza può costruire dei percorsi
partecipativi
oggi non possiamo pensare di fare vera
partecipazione senza conoscere veramente
quali sono i dati veri che riguardano i
fenomeni si parla dell'immigrazione
dell'invasione dei migranti quante
persone si fermano a ragionare sui
numeri veri uno guarda i numeri veri e
servono a raccontare che per esempio non
siamo davanti a nessuna emergenza
il numero degli arrivi in italia sono
stabili negli ultimi anni i numeri dei
richiedenti asilo sono addirittura in
calo rispetto a quelli che sono stati
negli anni passati
questi dati sono fondamentali per poter
fare una narrazione della nostro
quotidiano della nostra realtà basata
sulla sulla verità basata sui fatti
basata sulla partecipazione perché solo
a partire da numeri autentici numeri
certificati numeri veri che sono solo
quelli che possono venire dalle
pubbliche amministrazioni
noi possiamo poi fare quell iniziativa
civica quella partecipazione che è una
partecipazione concreta una
partecipazione vera che ormai sono
sempre di meno viene spontaneamente dai
cittadini ma sempre di più serve per
riuscire a mantenere un piede nella
realtà e rifuggire il rischio di
populismo piuttosto che di parlare di
fenomeni senza conoscerli che invece un
grande costo sociale siccome invece
vogliamo fare in modo che sia una grande
opportunità
lavorare con gli sviluppatori con chi
crea del dei servizi sulla base dei dati
della pubblica amministrazione è
fondamentale io sono arrivato qua anche
grazie alla conoscenza con un'iniziativa
che quella di ciocco data un gruppo di
sviluppatori di servizi online che usano
i dati dei comuni per creare per esempio
mobilità condivisa come usare le
macchine in condivisione per poter
spostarsi da un luogo all'altro ci sono
delle esperienze incredibili sul turismo
che usano i dati delle pubbliche
amministrazioni messi tutti insieme i
dati di chi fa e chi sposta aeree che
sposta treni che fa ricettività i comuni
che in alcuni casi applicano tasse di
soggiorno
messi tutti insieme questi dati creano
un valore perché danno una profondità
incredibile allora oggi la sfida non è
più quella di mettere fuori tanti dati
dire ci sono tante informazioni ma
quella di fare una open data una
pubblicazione di dati di qualità e per
farlo bisogna assolutamente fare in modo
di lavorare a stretto contatto con chi
lavora per creare un valore da questi
dati gli sviluppatori le persone che
hanno start up le persone che lavorano
con i dati e soprattutto vicino molto
vicino ai cittadini perché è importante
che questi dati siano restituiti con una
profondità che non può essere solo
quella degli addetti ai lavori ma deve
essere a seconda dei pubblici delle
persone che si incontrano anche la
profondità in grado di creare da queste
informazioni
un racconto un racconto di quella che è
la nostra realtà di come cambia e
di come poter fare da questa mole di
dati conoscenza conoscenza e
informazione che poi il modo di
restituire questo è lo sforzo delle
pubbliche amministrazioni come milano da
questo mole di numeri da queste tabelle
un po fredde un po informali la nostra
realtà il nostro modo di restituire ai
cittadini quelle che sono il nostro
quotidiano raccontare perché è
importante per tutte le età conoscere da
chi siamo e dove andiamo e quindi qual è
il modo di poter lavorare insieme per
ricostituire un po quella fiducia che
evidentemente è andata perduta se nel
giro di 40 anni abbiamo perso quasi
siamo passati dal quasi 90 per cento di
cittadini che partecipano alle lezioni a
percentuali inferiori alla metà solo
quindi mettendo a disposizione una
grande opera di volontà e di apertura e
di riavvicinamento ai cittadini delle
amministrazioni possiamo riprendere
questo momento questa fiducia che sembra
essersi perduta ma non dimentichiamo che
queste cose se sono calate dall'alto
possono funzionare ma hanno vita breve
sono come ai tempi delle radio libere i
cittadini che devono riappropriarsi
delle loro informazioni che sono di
proprietà del pubblico delle dei
cittadini che generano con la loro
attività e vita quotidiana perché solo
in questa maniera che veramente si può
fare in modo che queste informazioni
abbiano un'anima abbiano delle storie
dietro abbiano dei valori abbiano siano
dei beni comuni quali sono nate devono
continuare ad essere
[Applauso]